dieser platz ist schon recht geil und
zwar haben wir hier domino in minecraft
sehr sehr cool funktioniert sogar
löste bei der lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren top 5
ausgabe ich habe mir gedacht da in
letzter zeit gar nicht dieses top 5
format kam mache ich das doch heute
einfach mal mit den top 5 redstone
sachen die wie ich finde so je gebaut
wurden also ich habe jetzt nicht fünf
extrem steilen rausgenommen sondern
wirklich einfach so eine reihenfolge
geschaffen so was was ganz okay bis hin
zu wolf aquino sam und ich würde sagen
ich würde mich freuen wenn die bis zum
ende dran bleiben würden und das video
erst am ende bewerten würden weil ich
mir immer sehr viel mühe gebe mit dem
schneiden und ich möchte dann dass man
sich das video anschauen bevor man
einfach das bewertet das würde mich zu
einem sehr glücklichen luca machen und
ich weiß dass heute eigentlich die facts
dran sind aber freunde ich bin nur zur
zeit und machen mit dem feld so mit ein
paar anderen hat man auch keinen tipp
geben aber das wird euch mit sicherheit
freuen
eventuell wissen schon einige ich fries
ist ja nicht jedenfalls ist das da
zurzeit kommt dass demnächst ein
bisschen unregelmäßiger genauso wie die
command eventuell werde mal schauen wie
ich das ganze machen werde da wird auf
jeden fall das plus kommt fast jeden von
euch freuen wird denke ich wird aber
noch ein ganz klein wenig dauern aber
mal schauen ich würd sagen man jetzt
erst mal platz fünf platz fünf ist das
gebäude wo ich mich hier gerade schon
befinde und zwar dass das modern
redstone smarthouse in minecraft es ist
einfach recht etwas recht simpel es
genauso wie es halt ist mit den sos es
ist halt reihenfolge platz fünf ist
jetzt nicht so berauschend aber es geht
halt weiterhin zu recht krasse sachen
das ist einfach nur ein redstone horst
ich klicke hier diesen schalter und dann
kann ich hier reingehen
ich kann zum beispiel hier die kisten
rücken genau diese teile hoch alles so
ein bisschen mit schaltern verbunden das
sind die geheime eingänge wie
beispielsweise kann ich hier runter
gehen und ich kann hier drücken so dann
ist da oben der weg verschlossen so geht
es dann wieder rauf hier unten ist
dementsprechend dann so eine pipe anlage
oder irgendwie sowas wo ich hier auch
nochmal ein schalter drücken kamen dann
geht hier noch mal ein geheim weg aufs
deshalb quasi so eine verbindung aus
jena coolen architektur verbunden mit
ein bisschen redstone also man findet
hier wirklich überall so ein paar
schalter mit denen ich irgendwas
bewirken kann ich suche jetzt noch ein
andere dass da vorn hatte ich euch alle
schon gezeigt ich meine ja hier sind
auch noch schalter was sie hier machen
weiß ich gar nicht so genau acht die
machen hier das licht an und dann
wahrscheinlich auch wieder aus ja genau
da kann man sich das licht anmachen was
haben wir denn hier noch alles so wir
haben hier irgendwelche schnee da kann
ich aber nichts mit bewirken
ich weiß auch dass wir hier vorne
irgendwas haben bezüglich der garage
oder irgendwie sowas geld floss toppen
da kann ich hier einfach mal drauf
klicken und ihr seht sofort was hat sich
jetzt geöffnet lava pitt close to open
the gate lama spa phuket rückt man hier
drauf was ist jetzt passiert ich finde
es bis es bewegt sich immer irgendwas
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher was genau
hier passiert hier steht jetzt press
switch and drop in the water stream
bereit also ich drück jetzt mal hier
drauf treffen hier ein ein item rein und
mal schauen was jetzt passiert da ist
irgendein bewegt hier gerade aufgegangen
wenn ich jemanden kurz hoch gehen also
es ist halt wirklich so ein bisschen
architektur verbunden auch jetzt kann
ich einfach oben drauf laufen was ist
denn hier los kiefer cave and trends
oder ich weiß nicht jetzt ist halt so
eine mischung aus architektur verbunden
mit ein bisschen redstone ich packe
jetzt auch mal ein shader rennen habe
ich fünf total vergessen reihen zu tun
mit sieht das ganze ja auch endlich mal
ein bisschen schöner aus läuft jetzt
auch ein bisschen flüssiger weil bei mir
läuft irgendwie mit shader immer viel
flüssiger als ohne shader keine ahnung
wieso jedenfalls haben wir hier quasi
architektur gemischt mit redstone ich
bin runter gefallen fand ich allerdings
ganz cool für den fünften platz weil es
einfach auch wirklich cool die sein dass
ich weiß ja nicht wenn ihr ideen habt
übrigens für noch weitere top fünf
sachen die ich euch mal vorstellen
könnte eventuell top-5 haus ist oder
irgendwie so weit ich finde das haus ist
genau mein geschmacks und der noch
häuser sowas in der richtung dann könnte
mir das einfach die kommentare schreiben
wir machen jetzt aber auf jeden fall
erstmal direkt weiter mit platz vier und
das wird jetzt auch deutlich schneller
gehen freunde
platz vier hat nicht ganz so viel mit
redstone zu tun allerdings wusste ich
nicht in welche sehr ich das sonst
packen könnte und zwar seht ihr schon da
hinten da sind so steine so rot angemalt
oder ich weiß nicht sieht man das
vernünftig bei dem bei dem shader hier
ich mache das ganze mal auf times 2000
wenn die sonne dann ein bisschen höher
steht
das sieht man gar nicht gut mit dem text
mit dem schade aber ich probier's mal
mit dem schneider hier zu zeigen
und zwar ist es ein nicht ein rahmen wie
es dasteht sondern es ist ein paint
branche und zwar kann man damit jeden
blog einfach anmalen dafür seht ihr
schon hier unten im inventar hier der
neunte slot wo ich gerade drin ist so
ein rotes kästchen wenn ich dann um
beispielsweise einen kaktus grünen
farbstoff reinlegen seht ich schon in
meinem neuen spot des letzten aktes
grüne farbstoff und jetzt kann ich hier
mit einfach rechts weg machen auf einen
block nämlich nicht obendrauf sondern
ich muss an die seite von den block
klicken und dann kann ich denn anmalen
und ja man kann es euch nicht mit shader
zeigen aber hiermit geht's auf jeden
fall also ihr seht wenn ich oben drauf
gibt es nicht ich muss schon von der
seite dran klicken und dann kann ich
hier die blöcke anmalen in den
verschiedenen farben
wenn ich mir jetzt beispielsweise aus
dieser kiste mal was anderes raus nehmen
zb kakao bohnen oder irgendwie rot oder
so kann ich das ganze hier halt noch
eine rot anmalen das rot sieht man jetzt
an die da sind auch die kakaobohnen die
ich hier habe ich manchmal das rote das
sieht man nämlich auch ganz gut dann
werden diese blöcke hier nämlich
beispielsweise einfach mal rot und somit
kann man diese sachen quasi anmalen das
ist funktioniert auch alles bei einer
kiste also ich kann noch eine kiste
damit öffnen allerdings wenn ich eine
kiste an mahle ist es halt noch ein
bisschen verbuggt da wird der ganze
block angesehen genauso wie wenn ich
beispielsweise eine halb stufe war es
meine ich hatte ich getestet wenn ich
eine halb stufe hier dran marian wird
auch der ganze block also ihr seht schon
ich kann dann zwar immer noch da rein
laufen hier allerdings ist halt der
ganze block angemalt und naja das ist
noch ein bisschen verpackt deswegen ist
das auch nur platz vier es hat nicht
mehr viel mit rap zu tun ich wusste
nicht mal wirklich einfach wo ich ich
wusste nicht wirklich wo es in die serie
packen wollte konnte blabla jetzt alle
in den kommentaren
das kann doch nicht sein das hat doch
gar nichts mit redstone zu tun
was soll das denn du holen sollen ge
sterben bitten dich freunde ich könnte
euch auch jetzt hier fünfmal ins gesicht
knacken und ihr könnt ihr das nie das
könnte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr
freunde dieser platz ist schon recht
geil und zwar haben wir hier domino in
minecraft sehr sehr cool funktioniert
sogar fließt hier natürlich fällt alles
um sehr sehr geil muss ich schon sagen
meine damen und herren sehr
nice das ist nämlich eine kreation von
bmw von sad bling ich hätte es natürlich
auch in die komanis daran nehmen können
weil hier extrem viele command blogs
dran stehen und alles mit command
funktioniert allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht jetzt für diese top 5 reihe
nehme ich das natürlich noch von spring
dran
übrigens sie findet auch die links zu
den creation von den kreationen leuten
von denen erst von dem platz vier und
platz 5 3 platz zwei platz eins findet
ihr alles unter der beschreibung mit ihr
euch das selber downloaden könnt hier
kann ich jetzt beispielsweise einfach
mal reset klicken dann stellt sich alles
wieder auf und auch wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise hier mal wieder dort an
stupst und wieder auf reset ticket dann
stellt sich das wieder auf und mit die
scroll kann ich leider alles zerstören
das möchte ich jetzt allerdings gerade
noch mal nicht machen und zwar zeige ich
euch das erst mal wie das ganze hier
gezeigt ist dass in dem ich zeig euch
wie das gezeigt ist dass es auf jeden
fall gutes deutsches ding ist quasi so
diese kreation die das einfach ist das
ist eine rüstung ständer und der klappt
dann einfach dieses ding um also ein
liegender liegender liegendes wappen ist
da quasi kreiert und ein stehendes und
danach werden dann einfach diese ganzen
command blogs hier gemacht dass die
nacheinander unfall mehr oder weniger
also ich stößt dass ich das an und es
fällt dementsprechend um ich kann dann
wieder auf reset drücken dann ist es
ganz wieder anstehen und die frau all
dies kreuth alles und wenn ich dann
wieder auf reset drücken passiert auch
nichts das ist ein bisschen crazy naja
das ist auf jeden fall top 3 bei mir
redstone creation einfach weil hier
alles mit redstone volles und ich dachte
der stepping muss auf jeden fall dabei
sein deswegen ist auch platz nummer 2
von sad bringen platz nummer eins nicht
platz vier und fünf auch nicht aber wir
machen jetzt erstmal mit platz nummer
zwei platz nummer zwei ist eine sache
die sich so circa jeder glaube ich schon
mal gewünscht hat und zwar ein
unendlicher rollercoaster ihr seht schon
in dieser welt hier ist nichts aus wenn
ich mal auch wenn ich musste mein kater
aussteige sind wir schon dass minecraft
fällt ihr einfach runter und es ist
bisher nur dass hier kreiert allerdings
meine damen und herren ich spanne mal
hier wieder ein neues mein card setze
mich da rein damit ihr seht dass das
ganze nur funktioniert wenn ich da mit
drin wenn so und zwar fahre ich jetzt
und ihr seht schon überall da wo ich
hinfahre wird etwas neues kreiert sein
dass diese komischen teil über die ich
darüber gefahren bin
irgendwelche jobs über die
herunterfallen oder ob ich irgendwelche
steigungen hochfahren oder ob jetzt hier
irgendwie ein tunnel kommt oder noch ein
tunnel oder ich jetzt hier eine
wendeltreppe hochfahren oder wieder
einen job
das sind alles bestimmte sachen die
einfach vorher irgendwo in dieser welt
ich weiß nicht genau wo sie gebaut
wurden aber da wurden jedes einzelnen
abteile wurde gebaut also da wird einmal
so ein tunnel abteil gebaut dann einmal
diese jump barrikade einmal dass hier
mit denen mit dem feuer dann noch weil
sie nicht eine wendeltreppe dann wurde
dann noch beispielsweise hier diese
diese komische wendel kurve gekauft
kreiert das hier weiter gebaut und so
weiter hier unseren dreifach jump alles
mögliche wurde gebaut und das wird
einfach immer nacheinander gespannt also
immer wenn ich auf dem nächsten ding
hier drauf bin auf dem nächsten redstone
block und zweitens hotspot irgendeine
neue passage des infinite rollercoaster
nochmal unendlicher rollercoaster und
dementsprechend ist es quasi einfach wie
der name schon sagt ein unendlicher
rollercoaster wenn ich irgendwann den
boden erreichen werden die blöcke
dementsprechend dann dadurch ersetzt
mehr oder weniger und ich weiß gar nicht
wie es ist wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
nissan in ein anderes abteil hier rein
fahre also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
in den tunnel da rein fahren würde
wahrscheinlich wird's dann
dementsprechend einfach ersetzt hier ja
daran dass gesehen es wird einfach
ersetzt das auf jeden fall ganz cool ich
könnte jetzt noch zehn jahre lang drin
sitzen bleiben es ist quasi einfach ein
unendlicher unendlich achterbahn kreiert
auch von spring der king von redstone
linkes in der beschreibung falls sie das
selber mal mitfahren wollte ich ja ist
einfach nur krass ja freunde falls ihr
euch fragt wo der shader hin ist oder
allgemein die etwas bessere grafiken ich
befinde mich gerade in der version 1.7
das seht ihr hier schon und zwar playin
1.794 open 1.8 world music computer
prolog ab lpgs youtube-channel where he
showcases im new singe ich natürlich
hier die sichtweite auf 16 chance alles
hier richtig gemacht dieser sache ist
von lpg findet natürlich ein link in der
beschreibung und wenn wir mal hier in
die richtung fliegen gesät schon hier
sind extrem große redstone sachen wir
sehen hier schon hier ist ein keyboard
hier ist ein glas blog auf den ich mich
jetzt einfach mal so ich habe nicht
getroffen so hier stehen wir jetzt
passen und das hier ist meine damen und
herren
ein sehr sehr großer bildschirm ich
meine es geht jetzt direkt los und zwar
kann ich jetzt beispielsweise mal hier
auf dass die drauf hüpfen so ich muss
wieder hoch fliegen wenn ich jetzt hier
ist das jetzt angegangen hallo meine
damen und herren nach so freunde hier
sind die beiden knöpfchen ich kann hier
drauf drücken auf den schalter dann seht
ihr schon crafter butting world
conference on computer von crafter lpg
aus 3.0 das ist hier lpg ist der name
von ihnen gemacht ist und ihr seht schon
da vorne link diese diese dieser
querstrich und jetzt kann ich nämlich
beispielsweise einfach mal auf ein auto
springen einfach auf einen drauf jetzt
bin ich nämlich wieder hier oben und
jetzt seht ihr schon jeden moment wird
dort ein d hingeschrieben dann kann ich
da jetzt unter anderem auch
beispielsweise mal auf das drauf
springen dann werde ich wieder nach oben
teleportiert so dann seht ihr jetzt da
wird ihr zieht moment eine
hingeschrieben dann gehe ich jetzt mal
auf das l beispielsweise drauf so dann
springe ich mal eben kurz auf das l
drauf dann kann ich da wieder auf dass
die drauf springen ich weiß nicht wie
schnell die ganze wie schnell die ganze
engine das ganze hier schreiben kann ich
dass ich mich jetzt quasi hier selbst
darüber schreibe und dann springen wir
selbstverständlich noch auf das oder-
auf meine damen und herren hier und da
sind wir auch auf demo und jetzt hat er
für uns das wort gilt den geschrieben
dort steht jetzt das wort dildo ich
finde dass allein schon extrem cool aber
das ist ja noch nicht genug
sondern wir haben noch einen
taschenrechner ich weiß war gerade nicht
genau wie ich auf den taschenrechner
zugreifen kann weil
t
wem das ganze wird man versuchen den pc
einfach einmal aus und an zu machen ich
hoffe damit wird das ganze funktionieren
shopping das ganze ding runter gefahren
und jetzt ist das ganze ding hoffentlich
wieder an aber da steht immer noch 0 0
es wird super weg gemacht da oben ist
der kerl you later und man kann
natürlich auch noch viel mehr damit
machen ich werde jetzt mal probieren
einfach indem ich jetzt hier mal auf die
eins drauf gehe so jetzt habe ich da ich
da hinten jetzt eine eins gemacht hallo
de und da ist jetzt eine einst so genau
dann gehe ich jetzt mal beispielsweise
wo könnte ich dann drauf gehen ich gehe
mal einfach eins nämlich hoch ich mach
mal einfach einmal da vorne nicht mehr
teil das ist ja grad mehr mache ich mal
einen geteilt hier so zac haben wir dann
geteilt 1 durch zwei müsst ihr dann
einen halb- oder halt 05 rauskommen dann
gehen wir hier auf die 2 und dann müssen
wir selbstverständlich noch eben schnell
auf das gleich zeichen draufgehen und
freunde
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das ganze
jetzt hier funktioniert oder ob ich
einfach nur ein gleiches hin geschrieben
habe aber aber aber ich bin mir sicher
habe ich irgendwas falsch eingegeben
kann sein dass das hier calculate ich
kann mich auch gerade nicht mehr als ein
video ändern ich kann es noch gar nicht
anschauen weil ich gerade halt aufnehme
ctr nee das ist das ist einfach nur
control
ich werde jetzt noch mal enter drücken
ich mal weiß ich ob das dann mit enter
auch funktionieren soll
sonst tut mir leid was habe ich falsch
gezeigt aber ich bin ja auch nur hier
jetzt müsst ihr eigentlich der strich da
unten so jahr strich unten
aber wie ich das ganze jetzt ausreichend
ich weiß ich da oben ist er das
taschenrechner symbol der sonne pc
nachgebaut
aber wie ich das ganze jetzt aus rechnet
weiss ich gerade nicht richtiger also
wie das ganze genau mit dem kärcher geht
kann ich euch rechtlich richtig zeigen
tut mir leid ich meine nur der pfeil
steht doch auf dem kalkarer also das
doch gerade beim klettern oder soll es
in tastatur sein und das ist dass es
irgendwie calculate oder irgendwie sowas
ich fahr ich weiß nicht genau auf jeden
fall gesehen ich kann auf jeden fall
schon mal zahlen eintippen
man kann damit auch normalerweise halten
rechnen und ich meine sogar zu
musik hören also extrem krasse sachen
deswegen ich sehe hier vorne auch gerade
die taste wenn man hier nämlich drauf
hüpft weiß ich noch kann man steht dort
ja aktuell pgs youtube-channel ja genau
da seht ihr es da kann man dann einfach
draufklicken hier im chat und dann wird
man quasi weitergeleitet zu letzt pohl
die tat 10 da könnt ihr auf jeden fall
einfach mal vorbeischauen
der hat das ganze nämlich gemacht und er
macht noch viel mehr solcher coolen
sachen da können das ganze auch recht
selbst herunterladen
links sind in der beschreibung das war
es dann auch schon mit dem top fünf in
sachen video
ich weiß nicht genau wie das geht mit
dem kerl viel älter ich wusste wie sind
diesmal geht aber dann muss man noch
irgend eine taste drücken dass man den
kerker quasi drin hat oder musste ich
einfach nur noch mal inter drücken oder
weil ich wie ich will bratt total
unsicher ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
wenn es euch trotzdem gefallen hat dann
lass mir eine bewertung der eventuell
habt ihr ja andere vorstellungen die
euro-retter reihenfolge ist könnt ihr
mich auf jeden fall wissen mal wissen
willst wie fit bist und dann wünsche ich
euch noch einen wunderschönen tag meine
damen und herren ich mache mir jetzt
noch spaghetti und dann es sich die